energy
versus cues versus scent and we'll take
video for example all right let's just
look at video right video i cannot smell
you danika you look like you smell
really good but i don't know right i
just have to guess right smell amazing
okay that's what i thought so we take
smell out of the equation where we take
some of the equation
i am looking at a couple of different
modes that you are transmitting things
to me so because we've removed smell
because we've removed touch right we
can't touch we can't shake hands we
can't give a hug we are focusing on
words so verbal vocal and non-verbal
and so i think that when we talk about
energy we're actually talking about is
how we are transmitting signals with
those three modes so the first one is
words obviously the first few words we
say the second one is gestures posture
facial expressions and the last one is
our vocal so how we say our words sure
what research has found is about 60 to
90 percent of our communication is
actually just in the non-verbal category
so when we say energy i think when
someone walks into a room we are taking
in their gate like how they're walking
through the room we're taking in how
they wear their clothing we're taking in
how they say hello
here's a really specific example
when we are anxious when we are nervous
we are afraid let's take those those
skydivers right i guarantee you if you
were to ask those guy divers right
before they jumped out of a plane to say
hello to answer their phone hello
when we are anxious or afraid our vocal
cords tense and i'm going to do it for
you right now so you can hear so right
now my vocal cords are relaxed because
i'm having a good time we're chatting
but if i were to go into anxiety and i
tighten my vocal cords you can actually
hear that i go a little higher on my
vocal pitch and also i get a little bit
more vocal fry
so my vocal cords are tight it's very
very hard to get out of fry so i talk
higher and also you can hear it and the
more i tighten my vocal cords the harder
it is for me to get any kind of
resonance
so what happens is when people are
really anxious they'll say hey
hello
and we can hear it yeah it's like the
ready-to-cry sort of sound too
oh yes actually it's a very good point
yes it's exactly what we sound like best
way me when i'm about to cry
so we're listening right without even
realizing it too when someone walks in
the room or hops on video and says hey
guys
well let's take it down a notch this is
the most anxious hey guys
okay that's the most anxious yeah and
the next level which i hear very often
is someone answers at the top of their
breath and this is because they've been
holding their breath the whole time
they're a little bit nervous they go hey
yeah totally hello
yeah and we're at this we're talking
about we are accidentally signaling um
anxiety
versus now i'm gonna do the opposites so
what happens when i relax my vocal cords
and by the way you can try this with me
so hopefully you can try this at home if
you don't if you don't mind this is a
really helpful exercise so what i want
you to do danica you're willing is yeah
i want to take a deep breath and i want
you to say hello at the top of your
breath so hello
hello
there you go
way higher versus so now i want you to
take a deep breath and i want you to say
hello on the out breath it's going to
sound like this
hello hello
right yeah totally
totally different so if you try that i
want you to ask yourself
what voice are you using
yeah when you're
on video calls presenting talking to
your partner talking to your kids in an
interview are you up here
hey everyone it's so good to see you
or are you down here
that is the that's energy i think we're
talking about energy
we can literally hear it totally what's
the exhale hello
conveying because obviously you said
anxiety at the top is it conveying
confidence or is it just relaxed is it
power
hmm okay so this is oh this is a tricky
question i'm going to answer it with
another study because i can't help it
which is
our vote our vocal cords are very tied
to the rest of our body our breath our
chest the space we're taking up so one
study university of british columbia
found that winning athletes when they
win a race they take up as much space as
possible so they expand their chest they
tilt their head towards the sky they
expand their arms they often jump up and
down yeah when we take up space it
literally relax our vocal cords it
allows taking more breath so it could be
pride it could be confidence it could be
relaxation so when i'm at the lowest end
by the way if i just i'm gonna scrunch
my shoulders up and i'm gonna tighten my
jaw and i'm gonna
go like a defeated athlete a defeated
athlete typically tuck search into their
chest no matter how relaxing the parts
are it's still really really hard to
give you my full vocal power like you
can literally hear it
so the moment i
maximize my my space to lower my
shoulders i tilt my head up i expand my
chest
you can hear it in my voice
there are hundreds of these vocal cues
that we're listening for and so that
energy that we pick up from someone we
go woof
it's because we are listening for
anxiety and we don't want to catch it
we don't want to listen to someone buy
from someone be with someone date
someone love someone trust someone if
they're anxious so can we cue ourself
like as you're saying all these things
it seems like okay they'll you know
they'll say like if you're stressed just
take a deep breath or whatever so like
can we if we know we get some social
anxiety do we arrive at the situation
just kind of go
hi you know like whether you're starting
a call or whether you're going to meet
someone or walk into a meeting or a job
interview can you cue yourself and what
are some of the one of those things that
you can do to cue yourself because first
off there are you just to like
give more information for cues your new
book there are four different categories
of the cues and maybe you could say
those and then um and then go into what
we can do to like feel more relaxed and
feel more confident
yes so you just
said it perfectly which is i think we
must cue ourselves we have to cue
ourselves and we don't realize that we
are constantly curing ourselves when we
are asleep i think we don't realize how
often we are setting ourselves up for
failure or success
right so part of this is understanding
the cues you're saying to yourself i
love it when people say oh take a deep
breath or pause for a second because the
secret benefit of that the reason why we
like to take a deep breath or
we try to relax our body secretly that
also makes us sound better so here's a
couple things that you can think about
to actually cue yourself for confidence
to cue yourself for feeling like your
most confident self so the first one is
um try to maximize the distance this is
a really weird one it's a really weird
one i want you to maximize the distance
between your earlobe and your shoulder
oh yeah sure okay i know that sounds so
weird but what i often see on video is
people hike up their shoulders and they
tilt down their head and they go hey
good to see you
yeah
and they do that because when we're a
little nervous a little anxious we try
to take up as little space as possible
that study i mentioned with the athletes
losing athletes want to take up as
little space as possible why
they don't want to be noticed we're in
shame or defeat we want less people to
see us so we tilt our head in we crunch
in our shoulders and we're trying to
protect our vulnerable organs we tilt
our chin down to protect our jugular we
cross our arms or put our our arms
tightly to our chest to protect our
heart and our gut
so we do that instinctively and what can
happen is
we're getting ready for a meeting or a
video call and what are we doing
checking our email
so we have our literally checking our
email or checking our phone is the exact
position of the feet
by accident right
our our shoulders are tucked our chin is
tucked our arms are to our side we're
blocking
and so people wonder why they're making
bad first impressions or why they feel
so awkward at the start of video calls
because accidentally
like this and then hello and they pop up
and brought and broaden
so the first thing is i want you to
maximize especially in the first few
seconds of interaction the few first few
seconds before an interaction maximizes
between your ear and your shoulder just
that alone it's going to open up your
chest it's going to make your head go
high it will help relax your vocal cords
second i love a deep breath no
hyperventilating i don't want to i don't
want too much right and we also have to
be very careful to not be elizabeth
holmes
so elizabeth holmes
theranos if you've watched that amazing
documentary elizabeth holmes i think
maybe read this study back in the day
which says
the lower your voice tone the more
confident you're going to sound and so
she made her voice like this and she
ended up talking like this which sounded
totally fake so this is the lowest
i know it's crazy this is the lowest end
of your natural voice this doesn't
matter if you're male or female that the
lower end of our natural voice does best
so breath expansion lowest voice can you
fake it i'm really wondering this
because in this world today there's so
many manipulators
narcissists
um
gaslighters
there's just so many people trying to
take advantage of you
and and we get duped like i mean i've
been duped in my life with people and
i'm like man i feel like i'm usually a
pretty good judge of character and i can
feel their energy or get their pick up
more maybe more cues than other people
but i've been there before so can you
fake it and does it take like a
sociopathic personality perhaps that
actually believes in their bs
to be the faker like how do we decipher
in that world what can we how do we how
do we not get taken advantage of
so i have been there too i've been taken
i've been taken this is why i started
this research i never
i never thought this would be a book i
did it because i got duped
i got duped and i said never again
never never again what happened if
you're willing to share
yes so this so i started this research
17 years ago if you can believe it and
this was the height of my awkward stage
where um i really trusted someone i
thought again i thought it was a pretty
good judge of character i had felt good
vibes and good energy
however
there were red flags that i ignored
i had little
hints about this person
that i was like uh you know that feeling
yeah kind of like oh well or oh yeah oh
what i'm sure that was fine yeah yeah he
was having a bad day yeah i had a person
that i really thought was great and i
and as time went on i kept ignoring the
red flags i kept ignoring the red flags
and of course i ended up it ended up
that he was completely lying to me that
um so many of the things he had told me
were completely false or had a tiny
kernel of truth